turning now to the pandemic pfizer has
filed for fda emergency use
authorization for a second booster shot
shot for overall of their coronavirus
vaccine this one for people 65 and older
it comes as europe sees a rise in covet
cases as a new sub-variant of omicron
continues to spread all around the world
nikki batiste has the latest
just as americans start taking off their
masks an omicron subvariant ba2 is
spreading across the united states ba2
is about 30 percent more transmissible
than omicron and now makes up nearly a
quarter of new infections among
americans but it does not appear to be
more severe and so far u.s daily cases
and hospitalizations continue to drop
while deaths plateau in the uk cases
were up about 52 percent in the last
week and hospitalizations were up 18
percent almost three weeks after the
country dropped its last remaining covet
19 mandates
and in china coven 19 infections are
rising fast daily cases jumped about 14
percent in the last few days china's
less effective coven 19 vaccine and low
levels of natural immunity due in part
to severe lockdowns have complicated the
country's efforts to stop the spread of
ba2
andy slavitt former biden white house
senior advisor says for now americans
should not be too concerned what is most
important for americans to keep in mind
right now when there are waves again the
best thing you could do for your family
is to get vaccinated and get boosted the
second thing i'd say is that when kobits
going around again it is okay to wear
masks even if they're not required by
authority
the white house says cuts to covet
funding in congress could hit americans
as early as next week medical providers
will no longer be able to submit claims
for coveted treatments tests or
vaccinations for the uninsured and the
u.s may not have enough funding to
purchase additional boosters gail right
nikki thank you